una bambola crea la tua bambola ma
questo è un ordine ordini in
elaborazione che cosa il combinato
questa volta piangendo l'immobile
[Musica]
no
se nessuno ha detto che la giusta colpo
di quell'ordine diventerete una mia
creazione presto
[Musica]
buongiorno anita buongiorno sveglia
si sveglia vi aspetto
se noi fino quando vedrò che lo
toccherai io lo so però il figlio
no
[Musica]
vitale
vitale beh io ti abbiamo tuf e berlino
forse al piano di sotto
andiamo a vedere
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non succede nulla
ciao sono sempre ioni bambola you
vi è piaciuto questo le pentole nel
forchette le posate è stato fantastico
mi sono divertito un sacco e voi allora
ti sei convinta di
l'unico modo che hai per liberarvi di
tutto può essere finire qui come ti ho
detto tu sono tutti vedo solo tu ti
aspetto e visto dunque forzandone dal
mongolo altrimenti non ci lascerà mai in
pace
quindi tu rimani qui e bada merlino che
[Musica]
e col filo di cui parlava il bambola yo
ora mi basta seguirlo seguirà percorso o
presto sarà qui
[Musica]
la fine del filo è un gomitolo
ciao anni tempi certi tenuta nel mio
negozio era il nostro babbo l'hai o non
piacere più di tre sì
no
[Musica]
auguri domini capello timore di time
libero
sì perfetta questo è un capo bene è
stato un grande lavoro
la stella della mia collezione
adesso possono anche rilassarmi so caro
diario tutte le mie formule i miei
segreti e le mie paure le mie debolezze
se qualcuno dovesse mai e prenderlo per
me sarebbe ma questo non succederà mai
perché siamo sono in due quindi noi due
la mia collezione di bambole ma mi ha
anche dovuto usare il mio figlio
trasporto d'oro è finita adesso che si
così perfetta
la stella dei miei gioielli possa
iniziare con il mio piano un po di pace
[Musica]
sì perfetta
cosa è stato cosa è stato mai
cosa è una pallina grattugiata
sembra un foglio del mio diario il mio
comitato
il mio invito loro peggior bambola yo
del mondo io ho fregato mi hanno fregato
ma è possibile la mia creazione o no mi
ero dimenticato dei fili hanno
dimenticato dei pi li vediamo un po
sono riuscito a rubare il libro del
bambola yo adesso scopriamo insieme
quali sono questi segreti ma lo avrà
scritto qualcosa no solo che non carrier
non riesco proprio a capire quello che
c'è scritto qua a ok per al contrario la
formula la formula di di trasformazione
ce la posso fare
la formula di trasformazione recita
contrazione trasmutando bene trasmutati
o no devo ricominciare di nuovo
contrario est rasmo tanti lanus fit
campbell ex stadio no usa ex stadium
[Musica]
[Applauso]
successo che cos'è questo ho visto che
ero lì con te nel negozio del bambola io
ero sotto la scrivania
ecco dopo lui che ha trasformato in
bambola che ho fatto ho preso il diario
ho preso the trasformata in bambola e ho
toccato il gomitolo che è un filo
trasporto sono stato super attento a non
farmi scoprire però visto che è passato
tutto questo tempo e penso che se ne
sarà accorto che gli manca il diario e
credo che sia molto arrabbiato e che ci
viaggia cercando
dove il diario dove il mio diario dove
[Applauso]
dobbiamo trovare burton ha creato
qualcosa in queste pagine detto che qua
di questo diario ci sono tutti i suoi
segni esatto
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per
sconfiggerla sulle regole per cosa devi
darmi il mio fianco e lo chiamammo ma mi
sento alto è già arrivato abbiamo
bisogno è bellissimo freni che ho
trovato
e finita
sì proprio qui è il mio diamanti muore
non ferma si ferma a muovervi all
abruzzo
ve li dico morti vedi di calmarti no
fermo a rimetto il mio diario si non è
stato semplice sai io sono diventato io
il mio sogno è di diventare il miglior
bombolaio perché da subito ho sentito un
qualcosa con le bambole sai loro non ti
giudicano loro ti ascoltano
sei sono le bambole riuscivano a capirmi
erano le mie uniche amiche e loro non ti
giudicano puoi giocare tranquilli e
adesso come la mettiamo adesso
adesso io e il mio diario
[Musica]
a mio figlio
presunto mafioso sconfitto il bombolone
per fortuna
[Musica]